but let's talk about la la resistance
because uh i saw this meme first we have
this story from timcats.com two visitors
arrested in hawaii for using forged
vaccine cards
governor david ige as i pronounce it
made the announcement on twitter here
are these two men apparently they had
fake vaccine cards because you got a
quarantine for two weeks
here's what's fascinating there's a meme
on reddit
where like someone on twitter said
morons out here be spending 400 bucks on
fake vaccine cards when the vaccine is
free and then all the comments are like
that's how stupid these people are
they're so dumb you can just get a free
vaccine card with your vaccine why spend
400 bucks i'm like man these people are
really that stupid they don't understand
why they forget vaccine cards it's
because they don't want to get the
vaccine oh have you considered this
it's the weirdest thing to me uh i think
the big problem with uh
we're i think we're definitely see a lot
more of this we've got we got this other
story here this is this is uh really
interesting from mashable black market
for fake vaccine cards is thriving on
telegram oh yeah channels with hundreds
of thousands of subscribers would be
happy to sell you a counterfeit for 100
bucks now my understanding it is illegal
if the cdc logo is on it
that's what that's what i heard so there
was a report that came out said do not
buy these they're illegal if you have
them
if they're using federal government
logos masquerading as an official
document
but i guess and i'm if it's just a
postcard that says vaccine
must be okay i guess the vaccine card
that i had when i when i traveled to
venezuela was just a yellow card and it
said vaccine schedule and then the
doctor signed the vaccines on it and
then he wrote vaccines on it then signed
it and there was no official anything on
it it was just a yellow postcard i had
to show that in venezuela when i went to
the country they were like because you
have to have certain you know vaccines
down to the country so in this regard i
don't know how you how you enforce these
things you know these lockdowns that's
why i think a lot of it might be saber
rattling or threats of intimidation or
big asks
also could they even competently execute
it let's say they did impose the system
i mean i guess maybe you could say that
bureaucratic incompetence might be the
saving grace as we head down this path
of a
social credit system with american
characteristics and you have to show
your papers to function in life and also
the officials act like you know they're
being so beneficent like if you just get
this card you can live like an american
once again
how how disturb that was basically bill
de blasio new york's
god forsaken mayor on the way out that
was essentially what he said almost
verbatim you can go about your daily
lives and do what you did before so long
as you have this card you know you know
what i i'm calling it
the lockdowns are back
they are locking down cities
they're legit
unless you get a vaccine
to you in new york and san francisco and
new orleans the city is entirely locked
down
you can't go into any restaurant or gym
or bar or venue or theater or or
whatever
unless you have the vaccine that's a
lock down maybe it's gated the cities
are gated they're locked down well and
this also gets to the delicious
challenge for the so-called anti-racist
the racist anti-racist to
define equity in terms of outcomes
and and of course disparate treatment as
a reflection of racism in a case like
this if you have
ethnic minorities in this country who
disproportionately
do not get vaccinated and their lives
are made miserable as a consequence of
these mandates what are the what is the
answer what does ibromex kennedy say
about this and james lindsay tweeted
about this um everyone's got to ask the
critical race theorists yeah if the the
black population are the least likely to
be vaccinated then who is getting
excluded from public accommodations
right now overwhelmingly the blacks use
their own racism against them i mean
it's literally a racist policy to
implement i actually think
it's a good reason not to have vaccine
mandates because it creates racial
disparity
i oppose that stuff i'm in favor of the
civil rights protesters and that and
that movement i think public
accommodations should uh provide
accommodation to the public
i've always maintained that position
i've had a lot of conservatives who like
you know i've always argued i think if
you have a bakery and someone comes in i
actually said i think the baker should
write the message but i understand the
first amendment argument he actually won
on that one so maybe i'm wrong i'm just
like if it were me i'd be like i don't
consider it my speech well let me slow
down a bit the the bakery thing everyone
knows about in colorado
he was willing to serve uh uh serve the
gay couple who wanted the cake he just
didn't want to write specifically what
they wanted to write because he didn't
want to be compelled to speak to speech
i understand that my thing is like
in general so i think i actually agree
with conservatives in that regard what
i'm saying is if somebody of different
racial background or identity or
national origin comes to your business i
think you should have to serve them
because we're all tax payers here man
you're occupying space they're coming in
you should be able to throw someone out
for some you know bs reasons that being
said if they start screaming or yelling
or they smell bad or whatever you've got
civil disruption yeah you're allowed to
kick them out and things like that you
know what i mean no you're not though no
you gotta have them squat in your house
you have no i mean the criminals if
you're an illegal alien you have more
rights than a u.s citizen in some
respects it's amazing isn't it they're
talking about these vaccine mandates for
interstate travel meanwhile the border
it's just did you see ivory hecker's uh
she went down to the border and got
video footage of
buses coming back and forth and she
talked to him an incoming migrant i
think he was incoming migrant that had a
piece of paper on the back said i do not
speak english
uh where should i go to catch my flight
and on the back was his flight itinerary
taking him like into the middle of the
united states yep is that confirmed that
he was like in from across the border yo
joe biden was smuggling children into
others two days ago what right yeah
ivory by the way that was an exclusive
reporter
yeah tim cass picked that up man yeah
she went down to the border and she was
like what's going on and she got you
know footage of all this stuff
i haven't personally confirmed that he
was from across the border but it's i
think that's
sure that is correct that was the
message there's more than one they get
these manila folders with their
itineraries and they're like where do i
go now
and uh so what are we at we're at 1.2
million i think yep 1.2 on the books on
the books right yeah and also by the way
this i mean there's so many different
things that can be said about this but
this is the super spreader event it is a
rolling perpetual super spreader event
the open border number one forget about
the national security implications this
which aren't even talked about in
context of an open border and then you
know we just had the census results that
everyone wanted to talk about and one of
the things that's not talked about and i
hammered this home i don't know why this
arcane point stuck with me but in
relation to the open borders and i wrote
about this a bunch over the last couple
years when the trump administration
essentially made wanted to make
respondents to the census say are you a
citizen or not why is that important
non-citizens including illegal aliens
get counted in the census
consequently
the numbers ascribed to them are used
for apportioning congressional seats and
also
allocating hundreds of billions of
dollars down to intellectual localities
so that very few people bring this point
no one talks about this this is foreign
interference and all right right we i
can't remember who we had on recently
and i brought this point up because i
think california in the past this is
according to a heritage foundation
california gained one extra electoral
vote in in in federal election in the
presidential election because of their
illegal immigration population
so you know tucker carlson comes out and
he says this they're bringing in people
because they want to give them
citizenship so they'll vote for
democrats i'm like no they want to bring
them in because they get counted on the
census for the next 10 years then they
get more congressional seats to their to
their states and more power to elect the
president it is subverting our electoral
process and giving our taxpayer dollars
to people who did not come to this
country through the legal process it's
just it's an extraction on the system
it's basically diluting
it's disenfranchising
citizens at the highest level it's
foreign interference in our elections
and you don't even need a mass amnesty
then to change the system yeah people
don't realize that like when tucker said
this i'm like we don't choose the
president by a popular vote they don't
need to vote they just need to give
congressional seats to california so
that california can continue to
influence the federal government which
means california's laws will affect
wyoming if california allows people what
are they doing like free health care for
people under 26 illegal immigrants if
they're gonna keep sanctuary state you
can't deport our people
you know what the problem is i blame the
republicans
i completely blame the republicans look
if they're if there's a string of
criminals in your neighborhood smashing
out of the windows
you're like okay the criminals are bad
what do we do to stop them i know we'll
all pool our money together and then
hire a security firm to deal with it and
then you see the security firm being
like well we can't arrest them because
you know it's like well i blame you
you're the per you're look obviously
first and foremost the democrats are the
bad guys in this regard they're they're
effectively manipulating our electoral
system by doing this
where where is where's anybody to stop
him
the republicans pretend to be on your
side there's a handful you know the the
the rand paul's thomas massey um i think
holly's pretty good ted cruz seem is
okay but you know i really do think rand
paul tends to be
the one guy who's actually filibustering
and trying to stop a lot of stuff and
you get lindsey graham and mitch
mcconnell and what are they doing tucker
carlson called lindsey graham a leftist
like he's just a straight-up leftist and
mcconnell's like we had more tropes in
afghanistan i'm like these people don't
care about you they pretend to be the
the the the resistance to the democrats
are doing but they're really just the
gatekeepers to stop you from getting
anywhere near them
and in effect controlled opposition
right at the end of the day and i mean
it's a uniparty it's a uni party yeah
and and
part of it it probably is like the
superficial you know gotta go to the
right cocktail parties and you you don't
want to be attacked in the washington
post in the new york times
but the disparity the chasm between our
purported representatives and us just
goes grows greater and greater and it's
more transparent than it's ever been so
the question is are the bums going to
get voted out of office ever and usually
they don't get primaried because
incumbency is a really powerful thing
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you